race is not a political weapon to settle
every issue
the way one side wants america
is not a racist country i
am i am shocked and a bit embarrassed
for him tim's got the senator from south
carolina
of course a a key figure hated by the
left because he happens to be a black
republican and these are folks that
ask candace owens shelby steele asked
thomas soul the most hated people in
america by democrats are black
republicans
according to the democrats they are race
traders which is why you saw by the way
uncle tim
trending last night i'm not kidding you
had white people calling tim scott
uncle tim after like uncle tom which is
just delightful
you know why they were pissed at tim
scott i kid you not the reason they were
pissed at tim scott
is because tim scott had the temerity to
say america's not racist the leftists
were like
that's a lie america is racist you know
how we know america's racist because
we're racist
there's a certain irony to people
whining that tim scott said that america
is not racist
tim scott should know he's a black man
in america
who's reached wild levels of success
they say
how dare you tim scott say that
america's not racist
yeah uncle tom it's like no you're just
racist
that's all anyway so tim scott gets up
and he gives what was
uh i think a pretty good speech i think
frankly it started off a little slow and
then it really heated up and by the time
he got to the end it was really really
good so he begins
it's the only state of the union
response address i've heard that i
actually thought
was of benefit to both the republican
party and the person who gave the speech
i've seen a lot of them ranging from
marco rubio in the famous water bottle
thing
to bob mcdonnell the the former governor
of virginia speaking to
a house in like this sort of stilted way
in any case here was
tim scott he says that um basically joe
biden made a promise you know he's
violating his promise which of course is
true
he promised united nation to lower the
temperature
to govern for all americans no matter
how we voted
this was the pitch you just heard it
again but our nation is
starving for more than empty platitudes
we need policies and progress that
brings us closer together
but three months in the actions of the
president and his party
are pulling us further and further apart
and of course this is true and then he
continues and he says
you know joe biden wants to define what
your life is going to be like for you
but that's not the way that america is
supposed to work
he says the american dream is about you
defining that for yourself the beauty of
the american dream
is that families get to define it for
themselves
we should be expanding opportunities and
options for
all families not throwing money at
certain issues because democrats think
they know best
okay 100 true now here's the part that
really really pissed off the left is
when tim scott started to talk about
race
because black people are not supposed to
think this way according to democrats
democrats are racial essentialists
they believe that black people are all
supposed to vote democrat because
they say that black people have no
agency in america because of white
supremacy
but tim scott says no black people do
have agency because all individuals in
america have agency
and tim scott says a mature adult thing
which is just because you have
experienced racism from individuals
does not implicate the entire system of
the united states which of course is
true
as a jew in the united states i've
experienced some anti-semitism as the
number one target of online
anti-semitism in 2016. that does not
mean that america is systemically
anti-semitic
it's a tim scott makes a rather mature
point here
right so he starts off by saying listen
i've experienced some racism myself
again you're not supposed to say this if
you're tim scott because the immediate
follow-up
for democrats is if you say i've
experienced racism the immediate next
line is supposed to be
because america is racist that's to get
the bizarre spectacle
of lebron james sitting on his billion
dollars while doing propaganda work for
china talking about how america is
deeply racist and terrible to black
people
here's tim scott saying listen i've gone
through some racism myself
it happens to lots of people
i get called uncle tom and the n-word by
progressives
by liberals just last week a national
newspaper suggested my family's poverty
was actually
privileged but says tim scott and that
does not mean
that america is racist he says the only
thing that's racist right now
is the democrats who are pushing racial
essentialism and racial division
in order to gain what they want
politically a hundred years ago
kids in classrooms were taught the color
of their skin
was their most important characteristic
and if they looked a certain way
they were inferior today cues are being
taught
that the color of their skin defines
them again
and if they look a certain way they're
an oppressor
from colleges to corporations to our
culture people are making money
and gaining power by pretending we
haven't made any progress
at all by doubling down on the divisions
we've worked so hard to heal you know
this stuff is wrong
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country
it's backwards to fight discrimination
with
different types of discrimination and
it's wrong
to try to use our painful past to
dishonestly shut down
debates in the present that's
spectacular stuff fantastic spectacular
stuff there from senator
tim scott and this of course earned him
the unremitting ire of the media because
how
dare he point out the absolute truth
which is that they use
charges of systemic racism in order to
cudgel you into silence in order to shut
you up in order to violate your
individual rights how dare he and tim
scott didn't stop there right he
actually explained how they do this
he said you guys you want to racially
polarize us so that you can use racism
in order to get us to shut up about your
violations of individual rights and
constitutional bargains
he says for example he used hr1 as an
example right this is the federal
the federalizing of basically all state
congressional races and all elections
and hr one is a disaster area it
basically enshrines the possibility of
voter fraud and enshrines ballots to
harvesting it gets rid of voter security
measures in virtually every state it
federalizes elections
that is a violation of the constitution
because states are supposed to draw up
the way that they do their own elections
that was not given the states never
would have allowed the federal
government to do that ever
okay in the compact that was the
constitution of the united states it
never would have gotten signed
if that had been in the constitution of
the united states it's just blatantly
unconstitutional
but more than that tim scott makes the
point you know you guys are talking
about
the georgia voter law the georgia voter
law is not racist
the georgia voter law is more permissive
than for example new york's voter law
but you guys are lying about that
because the whole point of you
constantly talking about race is that
you can ram through an agenda that
really has nothing to do with race
this is not about civil rights or our
racial past
it's about rigging elections in the
future
and no the same filibuster that
president obama and president biden
praised when they were senators
the same filibuster that the democrats
used to kill my police reform bill last
year
has not suddenly become a racist relic
just because the shoe is now on the
other foot
race is not a political weapon to settle
every issue
the way one side wants it's far
too important okay he is of course
exactly right about this
but the fact that he's exactly right
about this is why the media are so upset
about it so msnbc had a whole panel
where they said they were embarrassed
for tim scott they weren't
embarrassed for the senile old man
warbling out 10 trillion dollars of
spending
to an empty chamber filled with
uselessly masked morons no they weren't
embarrassed for biden they're
embarrassed for tim scott
for saying true things about race
this is msnbc in a nutshell right here
people see him as being
genuine in trying to work on criminal
justice reform
and rather than make even one single
salutary point on that
he came out and lied about the georgia
bill saying it's easier to vote in
georgia than in new york
i am i am shocked and a bit embarrassed
for him
this was a lost opportunity tim scott
has an
opportunity to make his mark on criminal
justice reform and this ain't gonna do
it
she's unbelievable he tried to pass a
criminal justice reform bill
last year and he was it was filibustered
by the nail vice president of the united
states kamala harris
by the way if anybody ought to be
embarrassed by her by anything it's joy
reid
who came out in the last week last two
days and said that she jogs double
masked
outside like an idiot after being
vaccinated like a pathological lunatic
and i'm talking about somebody who's a
complete embarrassment to the public
discourse joy read each and every day
proves herself an embarrassment to the
public discourse
okay but don't worry the media the same
media who are ripping tim scott up and
down because tim scott's very very bad
they're praising joe biden to the skies
so jonathan k part
told the obviously abject lie
that joe biden his address had the same
energy as other addresses
um which is like saying that a potato
battery
has the same level of energy as a tesla
that's no joe biden was like
if you could have hooked up a heart rate
monitor to joe biden he was barely alive
okay he was nearly flatlined last night
but here's jonathan k part trying to
pump him up
i thought this was despite you know
having maybe a quarter of the people who
are normally there
i agree with lisa it was a much more
intimate speech
but i also think not being in the room
but watching on television
it still for me had the same energy
and i think a little more focused
because we were not distracted
by taunts or boos so much energy so much
brilliance so much wonder and if you
look at the headlines from media it's
the same
same thing the media are just the
propaganda wing for this party
the actual headline last night is joe
biden proposes more spending that has
ever been proposed by man or god
and old man shouts at moon right that
those were the two headlines
instead here are the headlines from the
washington post which are just
propaganda headlines
biden pictures his ambitious investment
and tax plans as he recasts
the role of government by the way it
took one two three four five six
seven reporters to write that headline
biden pitches his ambitious investment
it's ambitious and it's an investment
you see
they use exactly the same language that
he uses it's not an investment it's not
his money
i cannot quote unquote invest money that
i remove from you and just give to
another guy
with no return that's not an investment
okay here's another headline from the
washington post all of this
was on the headline of the washington
post page today
america is on the move again biden seeks
to reassure
nation reeling from a pandemic in
remarks to congress who's reeling
maybe you're reeling i'm not reeling i'm
in florida everything's great we're good
here's the new york times front page
okay this is from their webpage here are
all of the
like here are all the articles you ready
biden makes case to vastly expand
government's role
we have to prove democracy still works
he says president biden laid out an
ambitious agenda to rewrite the american
social compact by vastly expanding
family leave child care
and health care taken together the
collection of initiatives suggest a
breathtaking scope of change
sought by a president who spent a
lifetime as a more conventional lawmaker
the succession of proposals amounts to a
risky gamble
that a country deeply polarized along
ideological lines
is ready for more activist government
and then there's a picture of him being
applauded of course by nancy pelosi
and kamala harris and then underneath
says vice president kamala harrison
speaker nancy pelosi make history
on deus wow ladies with their ladiness
president biden kicked off his address
with a string of words no american
president has ever said before
madam vice president and madam speaker
okay i have a question define
woman i've been informed that gender is
completely malleable so why do you care
you can't even say that those people are
women if they don't say they're women so
well done media
according to the media tim scott was
terrible last night and joe biden was
magnificent
and then you wonder why trust in the
media is it an all-time low here's the
thing all this is going to come home to
roost
joe biden ain't gonna be able to pass
all of this stuff because he can't
reconciliation doesn't apply to many of
the things that he's talking about
he's gonna try and ram through as much
as he possibly can very very quickly
he's gonna overheat the dollar the
dollar is going to inflate there will be
actual cost to you there will be cost to
your business there will be costs to
your life
and then joe biden will wander off
he'll just wander off just like he
frequently does just kind of like
walk off and he won't know where he is
and then there will be a legacy written
about him
by jonathan alter or by michael
buschloss about what a wonderful
president he was
and you'll just be stuck with the bill
so recognize what this was last night it
was an attempt to bludgeon you in
submission
by saying america is bad and also trust
this nice old man to completely change
the nature of government in the united
states
don't fall for it just because the nice
old man seems like a nice old man
doesn't mean that what he's proposing is
nice
or decent or good or prosperous for the
united states it's none of those things
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist here
that is just science